vous venez de matériaux m'avait dit j'ai
vu brejnev projet vu bréslien il était
comme vous êtes là devant moi en aussi
bonne forme il a fait un exposé et son
premier exposé a duré une heure une
heure et quart tandis que voulait me
dire reflète un peu ce que vous avez
entendu sur la lutte contre
l'impérialisme progression maintenant ça
fait sa veuve en francs que je discute
avec vous avec vous mais vous avez pas
vous n'auriez pas comme ça vous arrive
on n'en parlait jamais arrivé pas vous
mettre dans votre petite tête que moi
aussi j'ai un cerveau et à c'est un mot
qui est capable de raisonner de
réfléchir et de formuler des
propositions et des appréciations la
touche aux stups ongles je ne suis pas
obligé d'aller je devais poste à prendre
mais est ce assez aller à ce que j'ai
dit dans ma petite tête sur une somme
bien je vais à l'étranger je discute
j'écoute et cetera
mais je suis quand même je sais je suis
peut-être qu'un ouvrier à vos yeux
mais je suis un militant ouvrier qui
avec mes camarades intellectuelle dans
son parti est capable de procéder à des
analyses qui tiennent debout
d'ailleurs dire son visage et a
contraint j'adore ces deux brochures
sait les rapports qui à mon avis que
j'ai fait au congrès et la résolution
souvent vous paierez ça a été fait au
mois d'aôut au mode de mars avril ça
jésus et bien vous verrez c'est la
justification de ce qui se passe
maintenant
bon alors